merci d'être avec nous en direct sur rt
france
cette expression michel onfray de
démocratie défaillant utilisé par les
économistes pour requalifier donc notre
pays la france est ce qu'elle est
utilisée à bon escient dans ce contexte
particulier un contexte sanitaire on
aurait pu l'évoquer maintes fois je
pense notamment à la crise des gilets
jaunes avec des blessés des éborgné vous
l'auteur de la théorie de la dictature
ne diriez vous pas qu'il s'agit tout
simplement d'un recul de nos libertés
individuelles aujourd'hui c'est tout à
fait ce que je crois c'est à dire que
j'ai écrit ce livre t rue des dictatures
pour montrer que nous n'étions plus on
lit en liberté en gym de liberté et en
démocratie ça me paraît évident depuis
par exemple 2005 c'est à dire quand le
peuple s'est prononcé contre le traité
européen et qui lui à un référendum qui
a clairement fait savoir que la pop ne
voulait pas de ce référendum et on a vu
la classe politique dans sa quasi
totalité
elle considérait que ce que le peuple
n'avait pas voulu
eh bien il aurait tout de même avec le
sénat et l'assemblée nationale c'est à
dire le congrès et je pense qu'il ya eu
là un genre de coup d'état qui a fait
que nous entrions en ce moment là dans
une ère qui n'était plus une ère
démocratique nous sommes dans une ère
post démocratique on pourrait ajouter
effectivement que nombre d'intellectuels
gênant ce fonds se font les uns c'est
moi j'ai été par exemple mis à la porte
de france culture ce que je gêne et
emmanuel macron nombre de journaux qui
sont subventionnées par l'argent public
la tienne un discours idéologique dans
lequel il dément n'y a pas beaucoup de
place pour la liberté l'intelligence on
insulte beaucoup les gens qui ne sont
pas dans la logique libérale de
maastricht les gens qui sont aujourd'hui
employées dans les médias français je
pense à france inter par exemple sont
des médias d'état ou arte sur des médias
qui sont qui fonctionne avec l'argent
public sont des médias totalement
idéologique dans lesquelles la liberté
est inexistante c'est à dire que quand
on parle de gens qui ne pensent pas
comme com com comme ces gens pensent et
bien on est considéré comme un nazi un
fasciste un p tit nist avec mon ami
stéphane simon nous avons lancé une
revue souverainiste cette revue
n'existait pas encore que dans un grand
nombre de journaux nous étions déjà
traité de fasciste de pétainiste j'ai
moi-même été assimilée à jacques doriot
par bernard henri lévy dans le point de
radio ce même quelqu'un qui a créé un
parti fasciste en france et qui a porté
l'uniforme nazi sur le front russe et la
liberté n'existe plus depuis bien
longtemps en france depuis effectivement
au moins 10 en 1992 je dirais que depuis
que nous sommes entrés dans l'ère
maastricht yens la souveraineté
française a disparu nous n'obéissons
plus qu'au capital qu'à l'argent aller
au marché et je suis bien heureux que le
comique permettent aux gens de s'en
rendre compte ça fait bien longtemps que
je parle tout seul dans le désert est
presque dans le vide et la légende et
corps effectivement que les libertés
sont en péril mais ça fait bien
longtemps que la radio la télévision
l'école l'université les grands médias
un la classe politique dans son ensemble
sont très insidieux de la démocratie
sauf que là elle est effectivement en
recul cette démocratie de manière
flagrante état d'urgence sanitaire
oblige
ce recul de la démocratie n'y a pas un
risque il s'installe alors pas de
manière évidemment aussi évidente mais
tout simplement la perte des libertés
individuelles
de manière insidieuse parce que tout
simplement on s'y seraient habitués
écoutez moi je suis ce qu'on appelle les
libertés individuelles aujourd'hui c'est
quoi c'est la liberté de d'aller boire
un coup au café d'aller manger au
restaurant de de sortir jusqu'à 3 heures
du matin dans des boîtes de nuit et on a
vu effectivement les beigbeder quelques
autres nous expliquer que le recul des
libertés individuelles et est terrible
parce qu'on peut plus boire des coups en
terrain se regarder les filles dans la
rue ce qui fait des lignes de coke dans
les boîtes de nuit si effectivement ces
salles recul des libertés individuelles
ça s'appelle le le recul de la licence
qui n'est pas la liberté cet égoïsme
s'est généralisé ne me convient guère
moi qui suis un homme de gauche est
plutôt de socialisme libertaire j'estime
que effectivement de pouvoir penser la
fraternité autrement et que les libertés
mise en péril c'est pas le fait que je
ne puisse pas par exemple - elle est
allée dîner ce soir dans un restaurant
c'est pas très grave
je ne puisse pas aller manger dans un
restaurant ce soir c'est beaucoup plus
grave que la presse d'état par exemple
applique au vide on s'habitue
effectivement a parlé de son état de
santé ya plus de secret médical je
parlais plus de ce genre de recul de
l'apico vide on est obligé de les
télécharger
c'est pas une obligation gens quand vous
vous retrouvez dans un pays dictatorial
si vous n'avez pas l'appli covit vous
êtes tout de suite en prison donc
l'affairé réglée là c'est votre bon
coeur messieurs dames si vous voulez
bien télécharger cette application qui
ne sert à rien d'ailleurs mangé le coc
vide
j'ai bien vu comment savent comment ça
s'est passé j'ai reçu deux coups de fil
me demandant avec qui j'étais je pouvais
très bien mentir donner des noms de gens
qui n'étaient pas avec moi de nepal et
de ne pas donner les noms des gens qui
est avec moi donner des fausses
d'information personne n'a vérifié
j'aurais pu mourir tout seul dans mon
lit personne n'a vérifié donc je pense
qu'il faut pas non plus exagérer
exagérer les choses citer michel
foucault à tout bout de champ parler du
bio pouvoir estimer que nous sommes
entrés dans une période fasciste non
nous sommes dans cette période depuis
bien longtemps et je trouve plus
dangereux l'unanimité idéologique à la
télé à la radio sont vous d'autres
d'autres médias je dirais ou à
l'université dans les écoles je trouve
ça beaucoup plus dangereux que le fait
que momentanément de ne pas pouvoir
aller boire un coup en terrasse ou
manger dans un restaurant
justement vous avez évoqué
virus vous avez décrit d'ailleurs des
des souffrances à s'est pas très bien
passé pour vous ça a changé votre vision
sur la manière dont le gouvernement
devrait gérer cette pandémie
non pas du tout - le 28 janvier de l'an
dernier j'étais sur un plateau de
télévision en estimant devant des
médecins qui dirait qu'ils disaient que
c'était une grippette que ce serait une
catastrophe épidémique parce que la
chine n'est pas du genre à mettre une
ville de plusieurs millions d'habitants
sous cloche sans de bonnes raisons donc
ça annonce effectivement une épidémie
planétaire et sûrement pas une grippette
il a fallu attendre des mois je ne
souviens que emmanuel macron en mars me
disait qu'il était encore au théâtre
avec son épouse qu'il fallait continuer
le mode de vie français les terrasses
bois un coup apparemment la civilisation
occidentale aujourd'hui c'est boire un
coup en terrasse bon aussi demain plus
que ça à défendre et si la l'utilisation
occidentale c'est ça moi j'ai dit très
tôt effectivement qu'il y avait un
certain nombre de choses à faire pour
protéger les français et protéger les
libertés en même temps on n'a pas fait
le nécessaire en son temps il se fait
que quand on n'a pas voulu tracer et
soigner les gens malades et les isoler
on a été obligé quelques mois plus tard
de considérer que toute la france était
malade et c'est évidemment un
problématique c'est un échec du
gouvernement macron c'est aussi un échec
d'une france qui a cessé d'être
souveraine ce chef de l'état n'est chef
de rien du tout puisqu'il n'y a plus
d'état
désormais on voit qu'ils doutent qu'ils
se demandent ce qu'il faut faire
il envoie des ballons d'essai à la
presse et on nous dit sur les plateaux
de journalistes qu' il va y avoir un
confinement mais qu'il faut pas en
parler que certains moi je me suis
trouvée sur des plateaux où on m'a dit
ah ben je vous donne cette info il va y
avoir des confinement dans certains
départements mais il faut pas utiliser
cette information
donc effectivement c'est la presse
aujourd'hui la presse mainstream bien
sûr qui qui qui donnent des informations
et le chef de l'état qui voit ce que
donnent ces informations en matière de
popularité parce que n'oublions pas que
ce monsieur dans le souci de sa
réélection alors les mesures de
restriction à danton par là pour faire
face à cette épidémie elle engendre un
vent de soulèvements notamment chez nos
voisins européens pays bas danemark
allemagne on n attendait pas forcément
là nos amis du nord en france sur les
réseaux sociaux
question philosophique au philosophe que
vous n'êtes que peuvent demander les
gouvernement au nom de l'effort
collectif n'est ce pas aux individus
finalement de se responsabiliser ajouté
le général de gaulle a fabriqué la vème
république parce que il souhaitait une
relation entre le chef de l'état et son
peuple quand le peuple disait on ne veut
plus de vous le chef de l'état s'en
aller
ou quand le peuple voter contre le chef
de l'état par exemple aux législatives
est bien le chef de l'état s'en aller on
a vu que girac mitterrand quand ils
perdaient des élections il restait tout
de même
donc c'est ce contrat qui est terminée
on le souverainisme n'existe plus on se
moque du peuple
il y a aujourd'hui des représentants on
sait très bien qu'il ya une idéologie
terrible une propagande incroyable dans
dans les médias de masse et qui nous
font voter pour un certain nombre
d'individus ne pas voter pour d'autres
individus nous avons tout de même des
représentants c'est à dire des maires
des représentants départementaux
régionaux et ses représentants ne sont
pas consultés c'est à dire que la vème
république qui supposait le contrat avec
le peuple
et bien aujourd'hui elle montre un
emmanuel macron alors que le contrat est
rompu avec le peuple et ce monsieur
depuis bien longtemps qui lui dit je
continue à gouverner tout seul mon petit
comité scientifique dans un bon coeur et
je décide tout seul je teste un peu avec
la presse instrumentalise la presse pour
savoir comment les français réagissent
mais je décide tout seul moi je pense
que la révolution s'est pas seulement
deux individus qui dans un endroit
disent on va faire un petit restaurant
clandestins j'entendais quelqu'un
l'autre jour de paris qui m'expliquait
que il est allé dans un restaurant
clandestins dans lequel on retrouvait
des personnes ou des personnalités
politiques importantes de monde connaît
en france qui était dans ses restaurants
plan destin on a vu que dans un coma
itam commissariat de police des des
policiers faisait la fiesta on a vu que
dans d'autres endroits etc
enfin tout le monde s'affranchit de ce
genre de choses mais je pense que il y a
des présidents de région je moi je viens
en normandie hervé morin par exemple les
présidents des deux présidents de la
région normande et lui il avait des
propositions à faire
il voulait lui géré régionalement ce que
l'état ne sait plus faire et je pense
que la vraie révolution c'est pas trois
individus qui ouvre un restaurant
manière clandestine
ce serait les chefs de les patrons de
région les présidents de région qui
irait faire
une espèce de sitting devant l'assemblée
nationale en disant nous voulons le
pouvoir que nous avons légitimement et à
ce moment là faire de telle sorte que
par exemple dans mon village natal
chambois 500 habitants on évite de
mettre des policiers pour faire de telle
sorte qu à 18h15 des gens qui sortent de
l'épicerie sans masque puis se faire
verbaliser je pense qu' il faudrait
faire confiance aux élus locaux aux élus
régionaux pour leur donner un pouvoir
sur ce terrain là le problème
aujourd'hui c'est pas d'ouvrir ne pas
ouvrir les restaurants c'est que les
restaurants par exemple mais aussi les
vieux de culture doivent leur destin à
la décision personnelle des manuels
macron qui ne s'est pas décidé c'est
l'homme du en même temps c'est je ferme
mes jeux confine et jeu des confiné jour
en même temps il faudrait le laisser
faire les représentants qui savent bien
si par exemple il faut faire un
confinement sur une plage balayée par
les vents ou s'il faut interdire les
balades en forêt est autorisée en même
temps le métro les voyages en train ou
les voyages en avion moi je prends le
train pour aller à paris quand il faut y
aller j'ai un voisin de francs - vasin à
côté de moi et un voisin dans la
diagonale de moi même et puis sur les
deux côtés vous avez aussi deux autres
individus et je voyage pendant deux
heures à 50 cm de l'ain et 60 cm de
l'autre et un petit mètre du troisième
donc on se dit si on est capable de
laisser faire ce genre de choses là on
doit pouvoir laisser ouvrir un certain
nombre de bars de restaurants dans des
conditions qui seraient décidées par les
maires en relation avec les présidents
de région
alors dans ce contexte d'incohérences si
j'ose dire que vous décrivez ya un
concept philosophique qui date à
l'origine du 19e siècle qui a réémergé
récemment depuis quelques jours quelques
semaines celui de la désobéissance
civile politique restaurateurs vous les
avez cité acteurs du monde de la culture
beaucoup l'utilisent a toute sa place
aux actifs justifié dans ce contexte
selon vous alors écoutez je vais juste
bon c'est un concept inventé par
autoroute est un philosophe américain du
19e siècle dont pourrait très bien
remonté 13 ans deux sens jusqu'à une
piqûre il ya quelques textes des piqûres
qui rendent cette chose d'impossible ou
même pops un philosophe du 18 du xviie
siècle
qui dans le léviathan nous dit dans
l'état de nature on est libre et on peut
on peut nuire à tout le monde donc
effectivement l'état de culture c'est le
contrat social et dans le contrat social
on renonce à la nuisance personnel quand
on obtient la sécurité de l'état mais
aube se dit si l'état ne vous garantit
pas la sécurité alors vous pouvez
recouvrer votre autonomie votre
indépendance est votre liberté si le
droit à la résistance déjà un bien avant
toro et donc je suis d'accord avec cette
idée
simplement il faudrait bien que on
distingue les désobéissance égotiste des
désobéissances civiles c'est pas trés
civile ou c outre et civique de dire moi
j'en ai rien à faire de contaminer et de
faire contaminer est de laisser se
contaminer les gens c'est une
désobéissance mais c'est elle et pas
forcément si vite plein d'enfants
désobéissent sans être dans la logique
de la désobéissance civique ou civil la
désobéissance civile
à mon avis elle ne fonctionne pas ici
c'est un concept qui ne fonctionne pas
quand des gens estime qu' il faut qu'ils
puissent faire ce qu'ils veulent quand
ils veulent comme ils veulent
ça c'est la licence c'est pas la liberté
et donc moi je suis pour des les
déconstructions contractuels qui suppose
que on arrête de se prendre pour jean
moulin canton un coton aux gens quand on
quand on gère des services dans une cave
de son restaurant et que on a eu
l'impression d'être un résistant non on
collabore avec le virus en collabore
avec la mort on était un collabo de la
mort on n'est pas un résistant de la
liberté il faut il faut pas se gausser
de mots je pense qu'il faut être
civiques et civils il faut faire
fonctionner la fraternité la droite ne
valent par la liberté la gauche de voile
par l'égalité souvent la droite se moque
de la de l'égalité souvent la gauche se
moque de liberté et moi j'aimerais qu'on
puisse se soucie se soucier de la
fraternité
je suis stupéfait que l'on puisse
aujourd'hui dire que certains
philosophes le font certains acteurs
certains intellectuels le dise qu'on
puisse sacrifier les vieux ils ont fait
leur temps dit andré comte sponville dit
nicolas bedos dit frédéric beigbeder dit
bernard henri lévy par exemple ils ont
fait leur temps les vieux n'ont qu'à
crever laissez votre plein ce on est en
train de sacrifier les jeunes etc
mais qu'est ce que ça veut dire cette
civilisation là dans laquelle emprunte
on propose un eugénisme des vieux en
disant ces gens qui ont travaillé qui
ont construit la france qui ont cotisé
qui ont rendu possible des retraites ces
gens là même
les scellés de mourir fait les crever on
n'a pas assez de doses on n'a pas assez
de temps pour s'occuper d'eux j'ai honte
d'être français quand j'entends ça la
fraternité a disparu la fraternité et
est morte de notre civilisation est
l'homme de gauche que je suis c'est à
dire qu'il pense qu'il ya des choses
intéressantes à droite la liberté
intéressante à gauche l'égalité mais
qu'il faut et la liberté dans la liberté
l'égalité mais dans la fraternité
cet homme là est évidemment extrêmement
déçu de voir si peu de fraternité et de
voir l'égoïsme transformer en
désobéissance civile c'est vrai que
quand on parle de confinement de
restriction est un un autre débat qui
revient régulièrement sur la table ces
derniers temps l'acceptation tout
simplement de de la mort 1 dans nos
sociétés occidentales
on était tétanisé on s'est voulu prendre
de risque d'où peut-être parfois les
incohérences de notre gouvernement est
aussi c'est aussi un argument de ces
gens qui je refuse la fraternité que de
nous dire on ne sait plus mourir ils
font les cadors et les gros malins en
disant moi je sais mourir j'ai écrit un
livre sur montaigne
moi je n'ai pas peur de la mort et ses
terrains très bien sont des gens qui
n'ont pas été malades sont des gens qui
l'ont perdue personnes autour d'eux sont
des gens qui parlent dans l'absolu et
qui font les malins parce que ça semble
ne pas les concerner moi je sais ce que
c'est que la mort j'ai fait un infarctus
quand j'avais 28 ans j'ai fait deux
années c'est dans l'existence
un accident cardiaque j'ai fait un
certain nombre d'autres choses qui m'ont
mis en relation avec la mort je sais ce
que c'est la mort ne m'inquiète pas mais
c'est pas mon problème qui est important
c'est le problème de la société ces
problèmes de la cité
je souhaiterais qu'on ait le souci des
petits des pauvres des humbles des
enfants des personnes âgées des gens des
gens malades et à accepter la mort
évidemment qu'il faut l'accepter
je suis pour une éducation à la mort
j'ai écrit un un grand nombre de livres
pour réhabiliter la sagesse de la
philosophie antique et nous apprendre à
mourir alors que la religion qui nous
apprennent à mourir ne nous apprend plus
à mourir puisque est là mais elle a
disparu
je pense qu'on peut aussi apprendre à
mourir aux gens sans estimé qu' il
devrait avant de l'avoir appris mourir
et laisser la place parce que place aux
jeunes alors amo michel onfray sur le
ramed a évidemment confinement et a
surtout dans la lutte contre le coc vide
les
axe 1 évidemment on est une chaîne russe
on va parler du spoutnik vécu la star un
soudaine inattendue depuis 24 heures le
vexin russe que l'on a beaucoup rails et
il faut bien le dire l'été dernier
rentrer en grâce à la faveur de la revue
médicale the lands est dans cette crise
on dirait qu'il ya eu de l'enterrer
géopolitique de l'idéologie politique
selon 20 minutes que ça il n'y ait que
ça dès le départ c'est à dire que le 28
janvier de l'an dernier je dis qu'il
faut confiné fermer les frontières que
le premier travail ne consiste pas à
envoyer des avions de l'armée française
pour aller chercher des expatriés en
chine en dix ans nous allons chercher le
virus qu' il ne s'agit pas de dire aux
militaires qui ont fait ce travail là
partent est désormais en permission vous
allez pouvoir disséminer le virus qu'il
ne fallait pas dire on ne fermait pas
les frontières sous prétexte que le
virus ignore les frontières
ça c'est de l'idéologie maastrichienne
la frontière c'est une catastrophe c'est
vichy c'est pétain et le nazisme etc
quiconque défend les frontières donc on
ne pouvait pas défendre les frontières
parce que d'un seul coup on aurait eu
l'impression de ceux de se déjuger
depuis 25 ans que tous ces gens là nous
disent qu'il faut abolir les frontières
et puis les frontières aujourd'hui
c'était cimente reçoit le voisin c'est à
dire que c'est la frontière entre moi et
quelqu'un dans un magasin c'est la
frontière entre le lait à l'immeuble et
l'immeuble d'à côté c'est la frontière
dans le département une époque on nous
disait ben voilà il département vert
rouge puis orange évidemment ça c'est le
range tes pour macron c'était le en même
temps et je trouve qu'il ya juste un
moment donné où il faut dire mais il
aurait fallu arrêter l'idéologie pour
protéger les français de dire oui il
faut des frontières non maintenant il
fallait pas de frontières ou alors des
frontières européennes et puis parce que
finalement les frontières c'est marine
le pen c'est philippe aux c'était je
parle dupont aignan et donc c'était
c'était les méchants d'un seul coup on
découvre aujourd'hui que le confinement
c'est quoi c'est la frontière au milieu
de chacun et de l'avis de tout le monde
donc il aurait mieux valu à l'époque
restaurer les frontières nationales en
disant protégeons-nous et puis on aurait
pu retenir contenir la maladie et cette
incapacité à le faire nous a mis dans la
situation dans laquelle nous nous
trouvons dans laquelle on trouve un
emmanuel macron qui bricolent dans la
cure à bhl alors une dernière question
concerne
votre prochain livre vous allez publier
on va le voir d'ailleurs s'afficher à
l'écran ça s'appelle la nef des fous ça
sort à la fin du mois le 25 février
précisément aux éditions robert laffont
peut-on dire qu'il s'agit d'un recueil
dans lequel vous dites consignes et
chaque délire dont notre temps est
capable notre société et l affreuse ont
juste plein de curiosité et de
contradictions mais tous les matins j'ai
une petite habitude je me fais mon petit
service de presse personnel et puis je
lis la presse je regarde et à un moment
donné j'avais commencé à faire à faire
des petits textes assez drôle je dirai
pas ce que le délire de notre époque est
assez sidérant
d'accord vous avez une petite fille de 8
ans qui arrive au cortese qui s'en vient
expliquer que depuis quatre ans elle a
envie de changer de sexe et que vous
entendez la totalité des députés
espagnols qui applaudissent se dit on
marche sur la tête là une petite fille
ya quatre ans quand elle a envie de
changer de sexe je pense que c'est parce
que ses parents lui ont expliqué qu'on
pouvait tout changer et c'est rempli de
choses ces extravagantes comme c'est
parfois drôle j'ai essayé d'être un peu
folle terriens dans le traitement de
cette information est effectivement je
photographie sur mon iphone tout ce que
je vois au quotidien et puis en fin de
mois
je fais un petit un petit journal des
bêtises de notre époque c'est assez
sidérant et les amis auxquels j'ai pu
soumettre le texte m'ont dit mais c'est
pas possible que ce que qu'on en soit
arrivé à ce point là nous sommes dans
une période de décadence de nihilisme et
donc j'ai cherché des occasions de
montrer que j'ai fait c'était
effectivement le cas
donc voilà c'est effectivement trop
chaud millions merci beaucoup michel
enfin nous avoir accordé cette interview
au philosophe auteur de la nef des fous
des nouvelles des bases entier en pire
aux éditions robert laffont à paraître
donc le 25 février merci à vous